so far we've spoken about all of the
wonderful benefits that sleep provides
but how much sleep should we actually be
getting
[Music]
for the average adult the current
recommendation is somewhere between
seven to nine hours of sleep a night and
what we've been finding from large scale
epidemiological studies
is that using that reference point of
seven to nine hours
once you start to drop below that your
mortality risk
actually starts to increase in fact the
center for disease control
in the united states or the cdc they
stipulate
a minimum of seven hours of sleep a
night for the average adult
in other words the shorter your sleep
the shorter your life
but it turns out that it's not quite a
linear relationship
as you would expect it's not as though
the more and more that you sleep the
lower and lower
your mortality risk is in fact something
strange happens
once you get past nine hours you
actually start to see a rise
back up in mortality risk which seems
rather
strange and peculiar and scientists have
actually
put forward at least two different
explanations
the first is that if you look at those
studies
it may be that individuals are suffering
from
significant disease and illness when we
become infected or we
have disease typically we try to sleep
longer we stay in bed longer
so in other words it was the unmeasured
disease and sickness in those studies
that was triggering a response in those
individuals
to try and sleep more that's one
explanation the second possible
explanation
is poor sleep quality because we know
that
sleep quality independent of
sleep quantity is also associated
with mortality risk and the lower that
your quality of sleep
is the higher your risk of death people
who have
poor quality of sleep will typically try
to sleep longer they'll try to stay in
bed longer
to overcome that poor quality of sleep
it may be poor quality of sleep
masquerading
as long sleep that is associated with a
high risk of death
rather than the long sleep itself but if
we take a step back
and think about society overall i think
modernity is constantly pushing us
to perhaps work longer hours and
therefore
neglect our sleep but if we want to be
around
long enough to get the benefits and the
fruits of all of that hard labor
we may want to think about starting to
prioritize our sleep some more